it's like right now when obama comes out
and obama says
uh uh just two days ago obama two days
ago comes out and says what obama says
what page is that on by the way page
nine obama comes out and he says um
where is it on page nine sorry page ten
go okay obama two days ago comes out and
says the following okay
uh he says open borders unsustainable
for the united states okay we have
borders obama said the idea that we can
just have open borders is something that
as a practical matter is unsustainable
as big-hearted as he is nobody
understands that better than joe biden
and the question is now are we going to
get serious about dealing with this
problem in a systemic way as opposed to
these one-offs where we're constantly
reacting to emergencies of the fifteen
thousand mostly haitian immigrants who
gathered in a makeshift camp under the
aborted bride borton bridge in del rio
texas thousands were allowed into united
states under biden administration they
don't care if they're vaccinated and on
top of that you know what the chief
doctor said they said 20 of them are
bringing some kind of a disease with
them here 20 percent of them are
bringing some kind of a disease to
america with them 20 of them it's not a
republican disorder is a disaster it's
an unmitigated disaster so they've got
kamala harris locked up in a basement
by the way here's aoc if aoc loves
america so much four years ago five
years ago she was at the border crying
three years ago what was going on where
is she at the border i'm sorry i haven't
seen those pictures yet the whole bed
stuff where is that at so do we have
border issue two years ago did we have
border issues two years ago were you
complaining about border issues two
years ago were we kind of getting it
better was was ice and those guys
cleaning up the place of that the people
that live on the border feel safer did
they feel a little safer as a resident
of the state of texas yes we did of
course you did this is what i'm trying
to so the part
that people there's there's a couple of
things here i'm not disagreeing with so
much at all yeah so the part that for me
if i see this with trump coming this way
he doesn't have my vote he doesn't and
this is what it is let me explain to
what i mean do you remember the first
debate that he had with biden
yeah how was
it he was a mess no i get that but how
was it just completely contentious it's
not a good look okay do you remember the
second one second debate was better he
just biden's calling him i just sitting
there listening to him and then he would
respond back yeah i was like wow but he
can't do that for two baits and debates
in a row i can't do that for two days
and fyi
fyi fyi
if he doesn't learn from him losing and
he goes that way he ain't getting
re-elected seriously and i know that
we're fired up we're having a great time
do you actually think trump is changing
even a little bit you think he's taking
this loss and being like you know what
guys i probably should have been a
little bit nicer and maybe the name
calling i can tone down in the tweets
he's not changing adam so you love him
for what you you love him for who he is
or you accept the fact that he is what
he is 78 years old he's not changing but
if i have a choice yeah if i have a
choice between him and biden to go up
against china it ain't even a question i
actually agree with you oh no you don't
agree with me on china if i have okay
you want to play this game do you want
to play this game let's continue this
game if i have a choice
i'm going to throw a kink into your
argument
if germany had to decide tomorrow
which country they were going to align
themselves with economically would it be
china or the united states
tomorrow
but
who alienated germany
trump thank you okay but that
there's an economic cost to making all
these enemies danielle
so danielle you're talking we have
children i mean doesn't it come down to
so let me ask you a question so what do
you do
so what do you do
you so you make a tough decision like
that you're expecting everybody to just
support the fact that you're going up
against china germany doesn't have an
alternative they don't have a choice
they don't have an alternative so what
does germany do what does germany do i
think does germany sit there and say oh
you know what
yeah you know instead of going to china
let's go to such no no they don't have a
choice because the last 20 some years
two republican presidents whatever the
thing is and two democratic presidents
helped not even 20 25 30 years they
helped
china get stronger agreed and they
deserve everything they're getting now
because they did that and now to go up
against somebody that's a monstrosity
you cannot have a normal person to go up
against them i'm sorry you know history
when churchill died one of the most
hated guys when this guy died
churchill wasn't loved but when [ __ ] hit
the fan they made one phone call when
chamberlain knew he didn't have the
audacity to go up against the guy he had
to go and beg the one guy he had i don't
think ron desantis would be would be
easy on china but that's not my question
that's not my question the question
isn't if the choice is
desantis or trump i did not ask that we
know if the choice is descent is where
you guys are going i got it that's not
where i'm going but all i'm saying is
that small percentage which is probably
not as small as you think it is that
percentage of trump becoming the nominee
and they're going against biden and you
guys going to sit there and go play
another game of i'm going to go to
george somebody else i'm going to do
this i'm sorry
i don't think biden or harris i think
both of their political careers are over
i actually agree with you okay so i
don't see running again there's a reason
the gop has no chance to joe manchin
there's a reason the gop is giving money
i think by the second debate
on the republican side we're going to
know who trump is
i think about the second debate
you honestly think trump is changing
even a little bit one percent one
percent you know what other way to put
this to you bro listen if if
if something happens to you your family
you want me as your friend
i agree
you're gonna make that phone call i'm
gonna use anything and everything in my
power to back up your family okay and
and you want somebody like me
to have some i just i don't think it's
the binary choice that you're making it
out to be it will never be trump against
biden mark my words okay fine though who
will be on the other side that's why i'm
saying joe manchin is oh that's a
difference
himself no i'm not i'm not i don't even
know if it'll be mansion i would like to
see something like that but there are
people in the in the numbers and the
democratic party
who are ready to take
a different conversation
but i'm saying the binaries of the
binary argument if it came down to trump
versus biden it's an irrelevant question
let me tell you something i
to to the point that you brought up at
the beginning of this podcast we're
debating over 78 year old men
can we get some new fresh blood in there
i'd love to see
uh ron desantis versus a tulsi gabbard
let them have hash it out 240 something
year old military people wall street
people she's a freaking beast why can't
we have that to be why does it have to
be old man river biden versus crazy man
trump why are those our two [ __ ]
options because the current system the
way it's set up these guys need money
and backing and to to get people to get
behind uh
tulsi like i said her and i are
exchanging messages we're going back and
forth she had nice words to say
obviously i had nice words to say to her
and what i told in front of joe is she
needs the powerful people to back her up
they know if we put our money behind
somebody they don't put their money
behind somebody without a good chance of
this person winning that's that's a
different conversation to be had so yeah
would you be would you be would you vote
for a tulsi gabbard rather than a trump
i would need to know what her tax plan
would be okay it would be purely
unattended let's say that you somewhat
agreed with their tax plan you're like
okay i can get on board i would
absolutely consider it you would i would
absolutely consider okay but it would
but it would be purely on the tax plan
okay so how many years have we been
having these types of conversations
couple years when it comes down to
america what concerns me the most tell
me what concerns china taxes would you
say would you say china's number one
on your list it's definitely in the top
two okay would you say china should be
number one yeah would you say my concern
about going to socialistic society as a
concern of mine that's in the top two as
well top two what do you think is next
after that taxes taxes which is part of
economy one part of socialism yeah
that's the same thing they're all
entertaining i totally agree with you
now you know you want to have the debate
the next things that come up is what gun
regulation background check i don't
think you give two shits about that i i
i i don't think that's at the top of
your list but believe it or not i have
very strong opinions about that and my
strong opinion is people need to be
trained more okay people need to be
trained way more like i'm i'm all about
training more i'm that's that's my
mindset so here let me try on top of
your list but i don't think it's in the
top of my head so you go through the
other stuff right so the top three that
you mentioned yeah they determine the
fate of the united states true those
three those three and those three alone
determine that you know you know what my
number three probably would be you know
my number three probably would be
censorship
yeah number three would probably be
censorship youtube youtube just comes
out socialism into the same yeah you can
you can put them in the same
silicon valley so so so to me censorship
is a very very big concern long term
because i like opposing arguments look
what just happened you know who won
today by the viewer do you know for
about 30 minutes yeah to us this was not
a podcast yeah for 30 minutes this was
not a podcast this is a conversation you
mean to tell me you want to take this
away from the audience are you kidding
me so the audience can't hear this kind
of discourse and they make a decision
for themselves screw pat i don't agree
with you fine screw you danny i don't
agree with you hell with adam no problem
make up your mind you saw this course
you want to take this away from the
american people well you brought up your
mind about the the debates that are
sound better
by the way is censorship
that's censorship they walk down they
walk down the same path
if you look at communist regimes it's
all about keeping information from the
people censorship
which it should be a four-letter word
yeah so anyways we're going to see
what's going to be happening in the next
uh
so should insider trading in congress so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]